I know that you recently started getting
managed by Paul Romer that's right
smells like tempos now okay there's no
one I'd know like lat last year at South
by Southwest not this one before you
opened it at Shady Day
yeah I'm a big fan of you alright what's
up mrs. rose we're gonna make that of
eminent they have man listen you never
I'm not that type of person to ever ask
for anything right nor do I ever expect
anything from anybody and that's not
something that's like you know explore
this woman in my mind right he's on a
different level
he's him you know what I mean if he
likes something he has to work with so
many requests then it's nothing that's
going to ever be forcefully and I would
never want to do something just as a
favor I mean you wanted to do it if he
wants to do it genuinely yes I'm all
about genuine there's only fantasy
people if I'm gonna make a path
you